[Musique]
depuis quelques années déjà le grand
bond de paris vers le ciel est amorcé
parmi ces constructions d'acier de verre
et de béton
voici la plus spectaculaire la tour
maine montparnasse ou tout au moins son
squelette percée par les portes palières
des ascenseurs encore à ce stade qu'à la
moitié de sa largeur qu'à la moitié de
sa hauteur
la tour continue à la cadence de deux
mètres par jour sa course vers le ciel
l'ascension une fois terminée elle aura
atteint 200 m et 56 étages qui feront
d'elle la tour la plus haute d'europe
mais plus qu'un simple record elle sera
surtout le campanile d'un quartier en
pleine rénovation
une rénovation qui commence cette
fois-ci non pas par des immeubles
d'habitation les par un centre
d'affaires c'est la maquette du secteur
3 de l'opération maine montparnasse dans
ces cent dix mille mètres carrés la tour
ne recevra que des bureaux autour de ce
gigantesque cerveau des affaires un
immeuble à usage commercial des galeries
marchandes un centre international du
textile trouvent leur place il n'empêche
que les amoureux du paris traditionnels
ne s'habitue pas à la tour il la trouve
laide
ils lui reprochent d'être trop voyante
de partout mais dans mon appartement
pas tellement heureux enfin j'espère
qu'elle restera pas dans cet état là ces
projets au lit jusqu'à maintenant époque
le lisco va chauffer pour dire le
contraire c'est con mais plus
l'achitecture de temps en temps chez
nous en france mais d'autres sont déjà
tombés amoureux de la tour dont surtout
sable a forcément un peu quand même
formidable
c'est pas comme une invitation à l'heure
nous n'est pas on n'est pas content mais
pas content
ce système de construction quand elle
sera finie simplement leur âne aspect
quand même disons
pour les les gens qui seront prêts une
vue quand même admirable bien cette tour
a provoqué bien des polémiques a suscité
bien des colères c'est pourquoi la
construction décidée en 1960 n'a obtenu
son permis de construire qu'en 1968 et
quand on ouvre le feu de cette façon
cela suscite bien des obligations la
hauteur en soi et 1 une discipline
difficile à maîtriser les questions de
structures les problèmes de fondations
vous savez que cette tour reposent sur
des pluies en béton ils descendent à 60
mètres sous terre a tenu des vitrages à
200 mètres de hauteur le
tourbillonnement du vent est très
important les problèmes d'ascenseurs qui
doivent être des ascenseurs ultrarapide
programmée par un ordinateur car un
homme au pied des ascenseurs serait
incapable de savoir quand ils pourront
envoyer des ascenseurs là où sont les
demandes des problèmes sont extrêmement
nombreux le conditionnement d'air vers à
200 m on ne peut pas ouvrir des fenêtres
un immeuble comme celui-ci et est conçu
comme un bateau où l'on peut maîtriser
dès le départ du moindre incendie la
zone où l' incendie existe et par des
cloisons étanches limiter l'extension de
cet incendie pendant deux mêmes quatre
heures avant l'arrivée des grosses cours
il y à peu près quinze mille personnes
qui vont travailler dans ces centres
d'affaires at on pensé aux problèmes que
cela va poser sur le plan des transports
dans un grand immeuble comme celui ci
les copropriétaires qui se voit dans les
assemblées de pauvreté qui ont réglé
ensemble de multiples problèmes
s'entendront sous notre impulsion pour
que le personnel sorte à une cadence tél
échelonné que le personnel puisse être
sûr de trouver sans attente les moyens
de transport nécessaires un peu moins
que la population de cagnes sur mer qui
va travailler ici à tous ces gens est ce
que vous allez leur offrir un nouvel art
de vivre leur journée de travail
la manière dont les équipes
travailleront dans ces immeubles très
éclairé trek bien conditionné au point
de vue acoustique résident les fonds que
le travail s'améliorent et donc qu'on
peut sortir plus vite au point de vue
conception du travail les américains
prétendent que c'est à cause de ce type
d'implantation que chacun sait ils
peuvent sortir de leurs bureaux à cinq
heures du soir
[Musique]